- [Narrator] This is Olivia,
a North American river otter.
Olivia is only eight months old,
but is quite the playful otter pup.
River otters are semiaquatic.
They live both on land and in water
and have adapted for both environments.
They have thick, protective
fur to help them stay warm
while swimming in cold water,
and short legs and webbed feet
to help them swim quickly.
River otters can stay under
water for as long as eight
minutes and use their
long whiskers to find prey
in the often cloudy
waters in which they swim.
In the late 1980s, North American
river otters were extinct
throughout many of their natural habitats
due to fur trapping
and poor water quality.
Through reintroduction programs
and the fur trade management
their populations have
risen and stabilized.
This is the North American river otter.